Andy Serkis is the greatest actor of
this generation
the ruling maestro of MOCA emoting with
his whole body so that his performance
can be captured and transferred on to a
digital character he played the dual
rules of golem and Smeagol and The Lord
of the Rings in The Hobbit movies he was
a hilarious Captain Haddock in
adventures of tan-tan he was
heartbreaking as King Kong he was
terrific playing multiple roles in the
criminally overlooked 2009 game enslaved
Odyssey to the West seriously go buy it
it's like seven dollars a game style and
he's why the simian Caesar and the new
Apes franchise is so sympathetic so I'm
watching Don of the Apes thinking to
phase one this new IG's franchise is so
much better than the ludicrous mid-1970s
movies they're based on and to its
outrage that Circus hasn't won an Oscar
yet why isn't he getting recognized is
it because you can't see him on screen
John Hart was nominated for Elephant Man
and he was buried in makeup or wearing a
bag over his head for the whole film
there was even talk of giving Scarlett
Johansson and not for the movie her and
we only hear her voice performance
capture has been around for decades now
long enough to tell the good
performances from the bad ones
if the Academy is too short-sighted to
recognize sin thespian excellence I will
step up and create my own low cap
Academy will hold an annual ceremony to
honor outstanding achievement in
performance capture I'm calling the
award this circuit instead of a red
carpet will have a green carpet huh the
best part no one actually has to attend
in person and if Joan Rivers makes fun
of anyone's outfit we'll just swap in a
new one in post
what role would you like to see circus
tackle next I'm hoping he adds menacing
gravitas to Skeletor in the masters of
the universe reboot let me know what you
think in the comments